Film Courage: Do you think there’s a story
structure that professionals use?
Andrew Horng, Screenwriter: I think it’s
different for everybody.
I don’t think there is one story structure
that fits everything.
A lot of people talk about three-act structure,
I kind of dog on it a little bit because I
think it really over-simplifies everything.
There are some books (that I won’t name)
that say that you need to have this happen
on this page and it’s very strict.
I think that just as long as you have a main
character that you for some reason really
care about and there is conflict present and
that conflict escalates and keeps on escalating
and you’re still engaged as an audience
member, that’s what the professional writers
use.
But in terms of one structure, I don’t really
believe that there is one out there.
Film Courage: Well I know in just watching
BACK TO THE FUTURE and doing the script analysis
with you, different beats didn’t seem like
they were being met exactly when some of these
story structure experts say they should but
it still works.
So I was just wondering what your thoughts
are?
Andrew Horng: Yeah, whatever really helps
you as a writer.
I mean I know BACK TO THE FUTURE it does fit
into the three-act structure, but I would
just warn against some people…like some
writers think it’s like screenwriting religion.
And I would just say that there are plenty
of films that don’t fit three-act structure.